what is going on everybody welcome to
part six of the generative python
transformers videos
in this video we're going to be just
kind of testing and tinkering with the
uh latest model that i have trained on a
much larger data set for a much longer
period of time now
from what we've found you can train your
own
pretty quickly and easily but i'll also
um host this model for anyone who's
interested so
i will at least host on nnfs.io
so i don't know if anybody's heard of
the website but uh
also on that same website it turns out
you can get access to
the nnfs or neural networks from scratch
book which is building neural networks
from scratch in python
essentially building your own framework
but the reason isn't necessarily so you
can write your own framework but
instead to give you a much better
understanding of the frameworks like
tensorflow
or pi torch that you might be using so
anyways
check that out if you're interested
otherwise
like i said i'll put the model in the
description a link just so you can
download it essentially it'll be this gp
gpit1 directory inside of which we've
got the tokenizer from the
75 wow you can't see that
great start to the video um
anyways it'll be this gpi t1 directory
inside of which you've got the tokenizer
from the 75 gig
data set that i had and then also the
latest model which contains all the
model files
as well as the optimizer so if you
wanted to keep going
uh with my training you could or if you
wanted to fine tune
and all that stuff so anyways that'll be
there i also might put it up on hugging
face at some point
i don't know if i want to train it
further or what i want to do i also
don't know exactly how to put it up i
just know that you can
um so maybe i'll make that available as
well
so uh with that uh let's go ahead
and do some tinkering so let me pull
over some notes
as well and what i'd like to do
is just kind of like show the the model
as it is
uh in this state and then also kind of
talk about
like one of the many use cases but also
kind of where to go from here so
um so what i think we'll do is we'll
just kind of modify
this uh we don't need to do
we're not training anymore we're not
data collating
we don't need this we really only need
this first
import uh we don't need this and
uh i'm going to get rid of that input
even too
making quite a few deletes we kind of
want this stuff below though
so we'll get rid of this we do want that
model i'm going to change the name in a
moment
and then we kind of want this stuff
but we don't really want this for beam
and output
i'll just do this we'll say for now
we'll give it a good old pass and
i'm also going to uh
let's go ahead and cut this we'll make a
new
uh put that down there what did i ru i
don't think i didn't
attempt to run that but okay i knew we
weren't quite yet ready because we need
to put the correct paths for both of
these
so that will be um
what will that be for me is it going to
be yeah so that'll be
uh g pi t and then it's g
pi t one
right yeah uh and then for the tokenizer
it was
g pi t talk 75 gigs
so you can pass that in for the
tokenizer again you can use your own or
use mine
doesn't really matter then coming down
here for the actual gpt2
model we're going to grab this way copy
paste and then i just called it latest
model
um i'll try if i open like if i upload
another one
it'll be gpt like two and so on i might
come up with a better way
if i continue doing this for a long time
anyway um and then yeah don't forget the
two cuda
and also let's see
um yeah so i guess the only time
the only other time we'll need the two
cuda yeah is when we do the tokenize
okay
so let's go ahead and run that make sure
that works and then if it does we
will kind of check out the model as it
is right now
so uh let's go ahead and just make
um imp ids imp so amp equals
uh and then we'll just start with a real
real softball
in it um so the hope again here would be
okay let's finish the init method by
maybe some parentheses
maybe a good old self maybe a nice colon
and so on that's what we're that's what
we're shooting for so we'll do that and
then also let me make sure we are
prepared for
okay cool uh so that'll be the input
we'll tokenize it here we'll generate
this beam output and then
for each of those in that output um
well what do we want to do so in this
case number return sequences
um and in fact i don't even i'm not sure
why i use the word beam here i don't
even think that's act
really accurate um i'm not sure if i
copied that from somewhere or what
because really it would be like model
output and then it's not really the
number of beams that are getting
returned it's this number of sequences
um so let's say three map
unless i'm unless i'm mistaken right now
i'm sure somebody's gonna yell at me for
that previous video
uh we'll call it model out um
max length we'll set this to a hundred
we don't need it that big and actually
for a number of beams i'm just going to
go smaller
10 beams is kind of a lot um
so 4 we'll call it out in model out
we'll print the out so this should be
like token ids
right so so again in this case the the
the thing that we're going to iterate
over is not beam
in beam output it's um each of this
each of the sequences now interestingly
um
this is like the more basic way to
generate output but i will also
show um
you can like you can get if you wanted
those like beam outputs and the scores
and all this like really really deep
stuff what you can do
is modify this slightly so we want
return
is it like [ __ ] return underscore
dict in generate we set that to true
and then we also will do output scores
true let me just make sure that's
correct yep um so we can do that
and then when we do this the output is
actually going to be a dictionary
with three things it's like sequences
sequence scores i think
and then uh like scores and then the
scores
are like per that is per
uh generation per
beam i think so each map anyway i'll
explain it when we get to it so
let's just uh let's just start with 4k
in
model out we'll just print um
we'll print k and in fact um i might
actually
post this notebook so kind of what i
think i might do
is uh let's
let me just copy this let's edit undo
is that right i just want to leave that
old method just in case
we'll paste in the new method we'll run
that again
also if anybody's watching and you don't
have a high-end gpu to like
have trained a model on at this point
you can totally follow along you can run
this on a cpu
uh at least on my cpu for example so on
my gpu
this runs in about depending on how many
it's really a question of how many
number of beams and then how many
sequences you choose
to return at the end but really it's a
function of how many beams
are how much how wide is that beam
search going to go
but in the case of like something like
around this let's say
it's about a little less than a second
on the gpu
and then it's about four seconds on the
cpu so we'll just kind of generalize and
say it should take you four times as
long to inference but you can totally
uh play with this model on a cpu it's a
little hard to like train the model
but if you just want to play with it do
feel free you can you should be able to
download this model and and do exactly
what we're doing here or do other things
or try your own
um try your own um besides what we're
doing here like with autocomplete you
could try your own projects or
if you do have a gpu you could also do
the do the typical thing that you do
with gpt where the p
stands for pre-trained is like fine-tune
it to some other tasks so anyway
continue on so each of these keys the
first thing is the sequences so up here
these are your sequences
so if we said um uh
for um i don't know out in model
out sequences
print out in this case you'll see
they are the same thing as we had up
here essentially
so you can still access the same data
it's just formatted slightly differently
and the reason why we're going to format
those slightly differently
is so that we could in theory if you
wanted to
access both scores but also so you can
there's two things you've got the
sequence scores
these and then you've got um the
uh scores and that would be like per
mask so the first order of business i
think we'll do now
is we need some way of i think i'll just
do it like right above here because
we'll continue working here
we're going to quickly define the new
line character
that will be the new line tag that we
defined
and then we're going to define a couple
of quick functions here we're going to
say
uh encode new lines that will take some
sort of input
and all it's going to do is return imp
dot replace
and we are going to replace uh new line
characters
with the new line care that we set above
there
and then finally uh we just want to do
like the opposite of that so rather than
encode we're going to decode
and then we take that input and then
basically we'll do the newline character
here
cut we'll just paste it right here and
yeah so from here what do we want to do
so let's take this
imp and well
in this case we don't really have any
new line uh but we're
we're soon we're going to one we're
going to want to be able to decode
uh the sequences immediately uh and then
soon we'd like to pass a little more
than just duff in it
but for now i guess we'll just use the d
code in this at this point
so uh let's i guess we'll leave
this k um
let's go ahead i think i'll i'll leave
that and then we'll just continue
working down here
so so now we'll say for sequence
in model out
sequences what we'd like to do is print
um tokenizer tokenizer dot
decode and then it's whatever that uh
sequence is so we can print that out
real quick and you can see it's like
really hard to read this
obviously we've kind of already seen
this before so then we're just going to
decode the new lines so we'll just wrap
this in that decode new lines
and now it's a little more legible and
one thing we can do is i'm just going to
copy this over to somewhere where we
will see
some highlighting boop and as we can see
i mean it looks pretty good
obviously there's this again we had the
max lens set to 100 so i think it just
ran
out of length um otherwise these are
looking pretty good there's
some subtle differences here uh
interestingly
um for example uh here you've got def
in it and then you've got you know tabs
over for the dock string and then after
the dock string it double tabs over
not really sure exactly why it's doing
that and then here
you've got the def in it and then double
tab and then it continues with this
double tab so at least this one
i can sort of make sense of because even
though
we started with this the model
after a def in it probably the most
common way
the model has ever seen you know
subsequent stuff
after the new line after you have def in
it is with two tabs because and why
would that be
right it would be because the first
thing was a class
you know something with a capital s of
course uh and then
this was all going to be tabbed over and
then when you got to the new line
it would have been double tabbed as it
was
so um so that kind of makes sense to me
why that happened and then here it
actually
everything was tabbed all the way over
and again this is just based on
confidence right so even though the
model did present this to us
um it was less confident about this one
than it was for this one and then even
this one so something to keep in mind
my guess is it's really the model is
just confused because
we've got this this clear init method
that is
all the way left oriented so anyway
probably not the best test based on
these results but moving on
so we can seek model out sequences and
then the other thing that we can do is
so for example so we've got three
that three comes from not the number of
beams so if we set this to
for example five and run all this again
you'll see uh again we have three things
so even though we had
you know five beams going out and
searching we're still only returning
three sequences so the other thing we
can do is we could say
four uh uh we'll call it sex score
in model out uh
sequence scores we can just quickly
print the sex score
sequence scores what does do wrong
sequence says
scores okay sure
so there you can see the scores um yeah
they are negative
you also probably if you wanted to
really use them you could move them to
cpu and so on but anyway
that's how you can access this score for
that's like the score for the full
sequence
but if you want to go even deeper
you can um for example uh we can
let's check out uh
model out scores so let's print
model out just scores
and in fact let's print first the len
of that okay so in this case you have
96 okay what is that
that is for each of
the generated
tokens at each step of the way so
it's a little less than 100 but if we
change this to say 250
right because apparently def init is
probably
in total four tokens so this should be
2 46 so
let's go ahead and run that run this
blah blah blah blah
come down here and then yeah so you get
246.
so this what this is now so what if we
um
for thing in model
out well actually four um
for token for
to i don't know what to call this for
mask
token i guess mask token in model
out uh scores
now print len
mask token
let me see um and in fact let's just do
a quick break here
in this case you get five so we're just
going over the first
because there's going to be 96 of these
or 246
in fact so let's go back and fix that to
be back to 100
i'd say for now and uh so we have five
so where's this five well the five in
this case
is corresponding to the number of beams
because you're doing that beam search
so you're going to allow for the top
five beams and again why would you do
this
the reason for this is you have a score
for the entire sequence length
but sometimes the best
total sequence won't necessarily always
be based
on going with the highest confidence of
each mask
sometimes you want to go with the second
or third or fourth or fifth
highest and then the end result will be
much better so
the number of beams that's basically
what you're doing is per mask
at least as i understand it per mask
you're going with the nth
top confidence so the more that you're
willing to fan out
sometimes the more diverse results you
might get and then some of those diverse
results might actually be the best
results
so anyway coming back down here
uh we get five of them because of the
beam so
four so here four beam in
mask each of these individual mass
tokens
we can then again print lan
beam and i believe in this case we'll
see
52 000 yes so in this case
again this is going to be a vector of
all
of our vocab which is 52 000 it's going
to have the scores for
every single possible token in our
data set so anyway that's a that's kind
of an interesting one
there's so much cool stuff that could
come from this point uh so just
be aware of the existence that you can
you can dig into this but at least for
now
uh the main thing that we're curious
about is going to be
uh this right here so
so let's imagine um that we
are going to just simply do autocomplete
so in our case uh let's just take
uh we'll take this copy that we're just
gonna i'm gonna do define
auto complete based on
some sort of input we're gonna run this
imp is here cool and in fact
the first thing we'll do is imp equals
imp dot or imp
uh what was it uh encode new lines
imp that way this is encoded before it
goes to our tokenizer for
the tokenizers encoding so again this is
just adding that
replacing the new line character with
the newline token
we'll call it so that comes in does that
we get our model output and
i think probably what we want to do is
um
i think for now i'm gonna comment
this out uh do that this
um what i'd like to ask is
print um in fact i mean it's not
actually that long so
i think we could probably leave this in
um print
um print imp dot count
new line character
oh we need to actually run this
um imp uh we'll actually let's uh
we'll leave this up here and then we'll
come down here and we'll say um
example input equals um
uh let's just do um
let's come up with like a really basic
script so we'll say i think it's
matplotlib
inline is that acceptable matplotlib
uh the single thing so
first we're going to say import map plot
lib.pyplot as plt we're going to import
numpy as np and we're going to say
x equals um range
5. i think we can do this y equals
mp.random
um mp.random um
uh what would be an acceptable
um np
let's see mp.random is it normal
yeah np random normal and then we'll say
random this is probably not the way that
people would do this uh
normal and then we'll say size uh
len of x plt dot uh plt.plot
x y and then plt dot
show i know that's off the screen there
we go on that okay
so this will be like our our sample test
script um
for for autocomplete so let's say uh you
know so in this case as you type import
matplotlib the hope would be it would
auto complete as dot pi plot splt
or you would import you know you do this
and then import numpy and the hope
would be that it would return as np and
then as we get down here
the hope would be could start predicting
some of these things and then for sure
after x and y are defined
maybe a plt dot plot after a plt.plot
probably a plt.show unless there's more
things
you know defined you know up above but
something like this
so um okay so what we would do
um you know imagining this is our script
we might say
our input and in fact i think what i'll
do is i'm going to
cut this i'm going to come down here and
start working on it
we're going to say our input example
input and then for now we'll just make
it uh
let's just do this and we'll just see
how it goes from there so um
uh how do i want to do this logic i
guess
i'm trying to decide how i really want
to do this but i think what i would do
is i would say auto complete
so uh let's just do auto
complete example input and then
hopefully yeah so so the count of the
number of new lines here
is zero so that so we essentially want
to divide up
the output so we get the model out we're
gonna get that
um and in this case we'll just say
sequence
equals model model out
and then it's sequences and then we just
i think for now we'll just take the the
first one
so we'll say sequence
um and then we need to decode that with
our tokenizer
so where is
so it's just tokenizer.decode and then
we
we could decode the new lines first or
it really doesn't it's kind of
irrelevant when we do that step
so um so come down here
paste uh we will say decoded
equals that decode new lines uh sequence
cool let's go ahead and print
decoded
um what was our input okay oh wow wait
that's crazy it's kind of weird that ah
you forgot the as
and then it gets it down here but then
it automatically went
and imported numpy as mp i think that's
kind of interesting
what if we do this
what's noki it still does empire
and it starts doing this okay
okay whatever um
decoded um
i am kind of curious to always see the
decoded
but then we want to do the auto complete
is
going to be uh equals decoded
dot split oh shoot how the heck are we
going to do this
i wish there needs to be a way and there
might be like
to split without removing the thing
you're splitting by
i wonder split without removing
things split by python that might be
like a parameter
without removing the delimiter
what's this doesn't split
d no okay so the idea that i had is
looks
to be what you're gonna have to do okay
whatever
um so yeah that's weird
that should be a function that should be
like an extra parameter in split
um probably is someone's probably madly
typing below
anyway autocomplete dakota.split um
i kind of want to do this before the new
line
that way we can use the new line
character
it probably doesn't i don't know i don't
think it matters anyway split by a new
line
so autocomplete split by new line and
then
what we want to do is split up a new
line
um let's say
actually what i want to do is cut this
we'll say splitted
split equals that that's fine
autocomplete will equal
nothing and then what we'll do
is 4
s in split 4s
in split up to
oh shoot new line
count equals imp.count
so we'll take this new line we'll come
down here
newline count plus one
what are we going to do we're going to
say auto
complete autocomplete
um auto complete
uh what am i doing here plus equals s
plus new line character
man so even if you have like double new
line i think that should
still work because it would be like an
empty string i believe in the split
so so at the very
end of this let's just return auto
complete
and uh yeah
ac class autocomplete um
let me do the following real quick print
uh
20 times a dash
uh and then we'll do the same thing down
here
i just want to make sure we have like
plenty of space because i always kind of
want to see the decoded part
um like the full but i also want to see
yeah this okay cool so we never printed
the autocomplete so we'll go ahead and
now also
print ac do we already
what have we done here um split
for s split d code split by new line
okay
oh you're so oh goodness okay
so this is an index not a slice
um so we're saying hey new line count
which was zero
this is saying plus one so the first is
so this is for every letter
and not this one but this one so okay so
yeah
welcome to um welcome to python
um so colon uh
up to this number
cool okay so now i will
remove that and we are finally
to our point where import matplotlib we
say autocomplete
equals whatever you know autocomplete
this input and this was just kind of our
debug
information this is the true uh output
and it said as plt that's kind of
interesting i thought we were screwing
oh i i thought it was screwing that one
up for some reason but okay it appears
it worked
um i want to kind of clean up a little
bit
uh so i'll remove the split part um
and then just to make things super clear
auto
completed
cool we'll continue
cleaning up slightly uh i think we need
to do that
okay so this is like the full
um thing but just the auto completed
import map lib.popular splt
so that worked cool um so now
we'll go import numpy so we'll just copy
this and we'll make that
the new um and in fact let's do
this paste uh come back up here
and uh copy that come down
so we'll try this now so this one
actually has like a new line in it
okay so that one also um worked import
numpy as
np cool the rest of this again not
really what we were after
but how would the script know you know
so it's just
you know trying to figure out what the
heck we're supposed to do here um but
the autocomplete to the new line it
worked
cool uh what would happen if
we said num would it know
by that point no but then the next thing
it imports is numpy is mp
uh lame lame
num points really num points is gonna be
the suggestion rather than numpy it
might be like that might be because
of like how things are tokenized like
clearly
bro
yeah so like if you just import the next
suggestion like after so if we just if
you inputted just this
the next suggestion after that is to
import numpy as mp which
probably is the most common next import
so that makes sense
uh so i'm going to go ahead and continue
so we'll just do another one
so let's go to the next line where is my
okay let's see what happens after we
define x because that's not
very informative my expectation
is going to be that um if we at least
define why
that will be the first time that it
could be helped but let's see what we
get here
oh my gosh that's a little odd that's
not going to work out for you
um
oh no it does stuff here x y oh
um outrange plus one i that's just
i think we're gonna get that can't
possibly work that's curious
why would that be
yeah like that i didn't think that was
even logical like i didn't think you
could do a plus one but otherwise
it does work it's so close
to finishing the rest of our script
which is pretty cool
um but no oh no did we what have i done
oh this was the auto complete okay
so um arrange five plus one come on
brother
don't do that what if we what if we
enforce a new line
what if we do that what range three come
on
man
what was it going to continue doing for
j for i and ranger yeah
i kind of want to let this one keep
going
at the initial outset it doesn't i don't
think that's going to work out
um
take me there
oh no what a did you change
oh here we go what in the heck are we
looking at
let's copy and paste it let's see what
happens
if we uh if we take i feel like copying
and pasting on uh
in a notebook is weird does that work no
range object does not support dang it
[Laughter]
so it's not valid code it looked good
though it was good enough
to um to uh make me not
certain if that was actually gonna work
so anyway i'm gonna go back to the
hundred characters just because i don't
wanna go too too deep into things
but anyway so the x to new line and then
it at least defines why immediately
again it has no idea that that would be
the next thing it's just clearly
has learned that
so um what if we
define why what if we just say y
so i'm going to come down here uh we'll
paste this in
oh we we threw in a new line there yeah
that that was of course gonna
be weird okay gotta give it a fighting
chance yeah it still wants to generate
this weird you know it still wants to
say range three
right um that's not accurate that's not
a good
autocomplete
uh y equals let's say y
equals np we'll just start it off with
something
smarter okay okay
all right okay this is looking good
so so this
that's good i think right because this
will be anything from zero to one
i think it's linearly and then there's
five points along the way
so this
i'm giving it the sentex stamp i think
this is actually gonna run
so if we ran this it did it
it did it oh man that's so exciting
also again what's cool obviously it does
like this stuff
um this actually would still run this
the whole
the whole thing uh would indeed run i
believe because this just comments out
that and then
if name equals main yeah so this is
actually all valid
that is so that's cool that's exciting i
don't know
i just man that makes me excited there's
been a lot of
kind of not so great although i guess
most of the first line auto completes
have been
relatively acceptable um but this is
really cool to see for me so anyway
the actual so this was the full script
if we just like let it go but
again i think it's going to be very
difficult to know like okay at what
point does the
generation start to get bad um
i think that becomes very hard to
determine so
i think at least just letting it go to
the end of the line
um so far that those these have been
relatively decent this is not exactly
what we wanted but
this is actually pretty impressive
considering um like the five here
it knows why they needed to be the same
length because that was some of the
mistakes that we've seen actually so far
but
anyway okay that's pretty cool uh we can
continue down
on this script as soon as i find it
um i don't know random
i'm not sure how much deeper we actually
need to go and in fact i kind of want to
redo
this we'll come down here pasta
come back up here um
and obviously you know this stuff is you
know this is just one example there's so
many other things that we could be
like doing and checking um
random.rand um
random.rand is it is that i can remember
like random.random
i don't know let's check it nope that's
legit
ah it's so fun it's so fun to me
um okay so so how about one one more
thing let's go to tensorflow.org
and let me pull this over for you all
um let's see where is learn
i just just take me to the basic
tutorial
learn more see the tutorials
uh beginner where's your mnist
just take me to the amnest karas god
i just show me some code okay cool
yes um
we kind of want this to uh yeah so let's
do
copy this we're gonna
let's see if our model can make more
models
wait what just happened oh my gosh
i'm getting lost i hope i didn't screw
something up over here
let's see i think it was this
i think that was the what it was
originally i don't
i have no idea um
yes i'm getting so lost in this notebook
okay so uh in fact let's do
let's just do this
where are you gonna take us
that's interesting
um i take me further
take me further where is our auto
complete we are
we're going we're going deep we're going
to 512 now
because i i need to see i need to see
more of this
so auto comp what did it auto complete
did it just give us a new line and
that's it yeah
whatever um okay
i don't know what this is um i also
don't know what bn1
that's not really defined anywhere it
was looking really good
it got no good
yeah okay one of the things that i did i
did notice
a long time ago was padding so
as soon as you start seeing these
padding characters in the generation
you know it's gone bad so um
that is kind of one thing i've i've
learned um
so like in this case the pad would be
the next new line i don't know you would
know as you got close to any padding to
to watch out okay anyway um coming back
down here
let's just we'll just keep tinkering i
kind of want to leave that one because
that was actually kind of interesting to
be honest with you
um it does kind of like i bet it would
import for example
let's just see like what does it import
from tensorflow.keras
tensorflow.js import layers
so it did got that right um
okay so the next thing i want to do is
what if
what if we just do this so we're gonna
copy this part from the tutorial
so it just begins defining its
sequential model
let's see if it does that if it can
handle that
i might want to shorten the the length
again but uh
sequential we got down here tf keras so
it starts off by making
the hell happened here
it closed it off and then it does
activation rally that's not correct i
don't think
activation like that would need to be
inside the conf
yeah but
i i'm not just biased it's false i don't
okay whatever i'm sure that's a valid
thing but anyway this
is pretty i mean that's a
oh and defined sequential model with
three layers
um it wasn't three layers that wasn't
dense
gives a summary it knows wow look at
this
this is so uh it just it makes me giddy
and again
when does this start getting messy
actually i mean to be honest the pad is
clearly being used as an unk token
if you ask me um dot 2 device
2 dot 2 device
okay yeah it's cool
ah this is cool um okay what if we
what if we i kind of want to leave this
because i think that's cool
we'll come down here um we'll try a
couple more i feel like
this tutorial has gotten super long i'm
just having a good time
i'm just having a good time seeing the
results this is cool
and this is not really that long of a
trained model i could keep going on this
one
um this is weird it like closes it out
and then adds another layer
does all this what the heck
what are you doing
i really wanted is this to work uh makes
me sad
okay let's try oh wait we didn't um i
got rid of the imports
i kind of want to leave those cool
all right we'll try one more
i'm not sure really what else to try um
what did you do so we went to layer two
uh no
dropout model dot add i actually think
that
should work um
give it categorical ah model
model name model compile
it's close it's just not great and like
the autocomplete what did it give us
yeah give us like this which is close
but not
not really um oh and in fact actually i
think we passed
with the second layer so really all it
did was
add this not so good
um okay
i'm trying to think if there's really
anything else i wanted to show for the
autocomplete but i think that's probably
like what if we did this look i'm going
to try
one more thing like what if we do
sequential
come back up here we'll do this one this
is the one i think i see more often but
let's see what happens
like oh
it just wants to immediately go to like
this like
create model function which is kind of
weird
this might be like overly represented in
the data set or something i'm not really
sure
um what if we do this
oh let's do this too like will it at
least like finish
this line successfully hopefully
what you got for me is that correct
strides two padding same activation
value okay so it actually would
at least complete this line
nicely
32 5 strides two um yeah
okay yeah all right i think i'm gonna
stop it here
um uh like i said the model is uploaded
so if you want to try your own
autocompletes on
all kinds of different things uh feel
free
to be honest i'm i'm kind of impressed i
mean i think this is a
somewhat decent auto complete uh i think
the biggest problem
is even on my my gpu a titan rtx that
i'm running it on right now
uh it took forever now we don't have to
generate like if we are just trying to
do
uh line complete um where
is man we we've been busy today
oh my gosh did i miss it
um you know there's no reason why we
need to do 512.
um that's kind of silly so you know
maybe change that uh i might tinker a
little bit more with this
and uh you know who knows some other
things too let's try 75 we'll just save
that real quick come down here
because i think it should be sub second
at least
what is it too long
okay ah
it's longer than 75 huh
i'm getting sleepy um okay i'm gonna be
done now
um so anyway there are other things that
we can do i kind of want to tinker with
the
uh docstring idea and do like transfer
learning so
maybe i'll do that not really sure like
i said the model's up there so if you
want to try that you want to fine tune
the model to
your own ideas feel free
overall i'm pretty impressed with this
to be honest i didn't you know i trained
it on the
uh the dgx a100 uh over there um
or the dgx station a100 i trained it for
uh maybe like four ish
days uh i didn't even make it through
one whole epoch yet
so it still definitely could be trained
even longer but i just got too antsy to
i just really wanted to play with it so
um these are pretty good results so far
i'm sure i could make it even better i
think the next thing i'm going to do is
try
to transfer learn from the actual
trained gpt2 model
and transfer it to my data set
i kind of like to see how that how that
works so anyways
more tinkering to be done hope you guys
enjoyed this is a definitely a long one
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave those below
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you